you mentioned in Prior interviews for
your latest film fischeri that you were
looking for talented people but not
stars why is that the reason is love at
the peril of sounding not so humble I'd
say that the star part has taken care of
because in my area where I come from I'm
what is called the star material and I
thought that's trouble enough it don't
need much more stars and tantrums in the
phone and as far as this one star in
mindfulness concerned he was already in
the directors pocket SL he's slaved to
the shedule not to his ego so I wanted
similar people I wanted actors the
talent if they are stars and not averse
to the idea of having stars like for
example we had a star of a different
kind not as an actor but shaker couple
of the director of Elizabeth and Bandit
Queen has acted in the film but that's
that's because we are all a group of
friends we know each other and I thought
he could act in it it's like how mr.
Attenborough acted in jurassic park or
something like that it's out of
relationship that I called him to act
but otherwise I thought the film should
work around her schedule and not the
schedule around the actors but it's it's
a complicated phone anyway so we didn't
want to complicate it any further what
do you think give someone's star power
in india vs america is there is there a
difference in that star power that it
factor oh my financial is my style come
on last night so I'm I have great
respect but I'm not going to bring down
the technique or the technician before
his altar he left humbled himself and
that that's something I learned while I
was a technician
while stars are very important they
could over time be made and what have
you noticed about American stars what
what themes do you see in them aside
from being a talented artist see their
various kinds of stars on what what is
heartening is to know that a great
talent has become a star also that's as
iconic and most of the American stars
that I know have that part that body
called cogent and then
you